Mashable brings up the latest dating  Trend it's called winter coating  according to experts at the dating app  Inner Circle Winter coating is when  folks reach out to their exes during  cuffing season to rekindle that romance  right up until the spring fozia out  again it's like it's like reaching into  your your closet and pulling out an old  winter coat and putting it back on if  you know what I mean and over half of  the data surveyed said they have  connected with the former flame as like  the weather got colder really yeah so my  question to you too is would you ever go  back to an X when it's cold just a  warm-up  I tried Madonna I try I try to call my  lecturer  I tried a lot but didn't work too well  right so uh did you ever go back well I  know where I'm back no no no no